parce que nos vies se transforme
perpétuellement nous avons le devoir de
recycler tous ces matériaux
yprema votre partenaire pour un
développement durable
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans
équilibre votre magazine sur
l'environnement on passe tout de suite
au sommaire de cette émission à magny
les hameaux nous avons rencontré deux
photographes qui immortalise depuis
l'automne les plantations des jardins de
cocagne toujours à manille l'heure était
au grand nettoyage de printemps dans la
commune début avril l'occasion pour les
bénévoles de s'informer sur le recyclage
la base de loisirs de saint quentin en
yvelines accueille la 5e édition de la
ronde des butineuses une course dont
l'objectif est de sensibiliser les
sportifs à la protection de
l'environnement direction ensuite trappe
à la rencontre de deux étudiants de lier
ce coup droit revenu du maroc vous
découvrirez le projet écologique qu'ils
ont défendu leur but 4l trophy
mais tout de suite nous partons à la
gare de versailles chantiers pour une
exposition où des étudiants proposent
des meubles en matériaux recyclés
patrick jacques de dixmude pour les
images
ici vous avez du coup un meuble
construit entièrement à partir de
palettes que nous avons récupérés sur la
voie publique donc des palettes qui
venait d'un chantier donc complètement
laissés à l'abandon donc avec voilà
quelques clous on a récupéré tout ça est
fait ce meuble assez design
recycler plutôt que gaspiller à
l'initiative de cinq étudiants de
l'institut supérieur de l'environnement
de trappes une exposition sur la
valorisation des encombrants se tenait à
la gare de versailles chantiers du 4 au
11 avril l'idée montrer au public que
grâce à quelques efforts rien ne se perd
tout se transforme 40% du tout venant et
gaspiller et jeter inutilement
l'autre intérêt de cette exposition
était de prendre conscience à la
population de ce gaspillage plus peu de
gens connaissent dans l'intérêt de leur
montrer qu'avec un pot de peinture
quelques clous quelques vices on arrive
à remettre un immeuble en état ce qui
évite de le jeter de brûler de casser de
simples boîtes palette ramassé sur la
voie publique ancien armoire à pharmacie
ou vieux coffre à jouets ici on fait du
neuf avec du vieux sans manquer de
créativité importante ont donc c'est à
partir d'une tringle à rideaux qu'on a
récupéré donc des planches aussi de la
même façon toujours de paraître on a
beaucoup favorisé les palettes parce que
c'est beaucoup plus simple à travailler
et donc un grand pied assez large pour
pouvoir mettre suffisamment de poids en
eau sans que ça ça tanguait ça se
penchent donc ici va fermer la traîne
mais ça on a récupéré ça c'était un abat
jour de l'an pour toujours dans le but
de sensibiliser et d'échangés avec le
public des questionnaires étaient
distribués aux visiteurs une trentaine
de personnes a ainsi pu donner son
impression sur l'exposition pendant que
d'autres en ont profité pour glaner
quelques conseils bricolage
christian et jean pierre sont deux
photographes amateurs qui immortalise
depuis l'automne les jardins de cocagne
de magny les hameaux nous les avons
rencontré elodie moines pour les images
c'est terrible on n'arrive pas à avoir
les bonnes couleurs
observer et capturer notre environnement
au fil des saisons c'est la mission
comme il l'appelle que christian et jean
pierre membres du club photo de
saint-hilarion se sont donnés le smi
puis la pousse et enfin les légumes et
fruits arrivé à maturité c'est cette
chronologie agricole qui illustrera leur
travail et l'étape du jour c'est le
jardin de la ferme de bus loyer à magny
les hameaux je prends pas mal de photos
de smith kia soul et c'est encore on a
vu des salades qui est sp planter ou qui
attendent la pousse ma foi mais c'est
surtout bon le travail de la terre
encore qu'est la la il est tôt ça
démarre et
on prend plusieurs prises de vues quoi
sous différents angles
peut-être différent sélection de
l'appareil photo de vitesse enfin
sensibilité iso quoi que ce soit chez
soi en retraite ça pas mal et on a quand
même beaucoup de déchet faut pas croire
pour une photo bien réussi à beaucoup de
déchet
ouvriers sous les serres humidifié
arbres fruitiers le long des murs de
pierres ou potager en permaculture les
occasion d'immortaliser la nature ne
manquent pas il faut pourtant trouver le
détail qui accrochera l'oeil on y voit
faut quand il faut regarder leurs images
limaces et la présentation sa
présentation les objets tout ça pour
pour ne pas faire pour ne pas avoir le
regard glisse parce que si un regard
glisse sur une photo que nul n'est pas
la peine mais au contraire là où petit
truc qui accroche
le travail du club va continuer tout ce
printemps les photographes exposeront
ensuite dès le 1er juin aux jardins de
cocagne et à la ferme de grandes maisons
à magny les hameaux
les beaux jours sont de retour et il
faut laver la nature de ces déchets le 5
avril l'heure était au grand nettoyage
de printemps à magny les hameaux
reportage
une journée consacrée aux biens de la
nature le 5 avril la commune de magny
les hameaux a donné rendez-vous à ses
citoyens pour le traditionnel nettoyage
de printemps un nettoyage qui débutait
par un stand d'information sur le parvis
de la mairie l'objectif dialoguer et à
prendre sur le tri des déchets dessins
animés pédagogique jeu de tri ou
échantillons une association accueilli
le public pour faire comprendre
l'urgence de la situation il est temps
que les gens prennent conscience de la
pollution qui peut être évitée grâce au
tri on a plus en plus de poubelles on
peut aller jusqu'à 500 kilos d'ordures
ménagères par habitant en france par an
c'est énorme
quatre parcours de nettoyage des marées
ensuite de l'hôtel de ville réuni 150
personnes jeunes et moins jeunes de
parcours en lisière de forêt et deux
parcours en coeur de ville avec le même
but sensibiliser le public à la
protection de l'environnement on a la
censure magny les hameaux d'avoir
beaucoup d espaces verts et justement on
se rend compte au travers ces espaces
d'art qui a quand même pas mal de déchet
dessus c'est un petit peu moins
heureuses agréable pour eux pour pour
jouer pour s'amuser donc l'idéal c'est
les responsabilités à ce niveau là et
qui savent ce que c'est à eux de
préserver aussi l'environnement dans
lequel ils sont c'est pas la première
fois qu'on y participe
c'est ça fait plusieurs années qu'on le
fait et je trouve ça inutile quoi en fin
d'après-midi les déchets étaient réunis
sur le parvis pour un tri métaux verre
et plastique séparer le tout était
ensuite acheminés vers la déchetterie
la base de loisirs de saint quentin en
yvelines accueillez la cinquième édition
de la ronde des butineuses un trail dans
l'objectif est de sensibiliser les
sportifs à la protection de
l'environnement anthony rech patrick
jacques de dixmude
la ronde des butineuses une course à
travers la forêt pour alerter sur la
condition des abeilles ces petits
insectes si essentiel dans le cycle de
la pollinisation mais exposée aux
conséquences du réchauffement climatique
relativement une sauvegarde sur ce que
sur le péril de la bei on s'aperçoit
qu'en région parisienne en fin de compte
on est relativement peu atteints par les
maladies qu'ils veulent et qui peuvent
être
retrouvés sur les abeilles on trouve
énormément diversité c'est ce qui fait
la force de certains de notre nature et
de notre environnement dans le cadre du
projet abeille sentinelle de
l'environnement la base de loisirs de
saint quentin en yvelines accueille cinq
ruches dans sa ferme pédagogique
après cinq éditions et de nombreuses
opérations de sensibilisation les
coureurs de la ronde des butineuses
deviennent de plus en plus écolo lors de
leurs foulées dans les bois la mentalité
a évolué parce qu'il ya de plus en plus
de travail de plus en plus de courses
nature et donc les gens pour les
sensibilise à six a sérieusement sur ce
point là c'est surtout dans l'adn des
traileurs les autres coureurs ne sont
pas toujours très sensible on voit
beaucoup de coureurs prendre un gobelet
le jeter dans la nature
prendre des tubes de miel et les jeter
dans la nature ça c'est pas bon c'est
indispensable
d'ailleurs tous les trailer dégel on en
permanence heureux de plus en plus j'en
vois de moins en moins pardon sur le
parcours maintenant les gens sont
vraiment mobilisés à tenir compte de
vraiment la nature des déchets dans
l'avenir
répartie sur quatre épreuves cette
cinquième édition de la ronde des
butineuses a accueilli 4 190
participants
deux étudiants de liesse à trappes ont
participé au 4l trophy afin de défendre
un projet écologique au maroc nous les
avons rencontré elodie moines pour les
images
un voyage au nom de la biodiversité
c'est en préparant le dernier 4l trophy
que diane et florian deux étudiants de
l'institut supérieur de l'environnement
de trappes développe un projet
écologique autour de l'abeille leurs
idées durant les dix journées de course
consacré 24 heures un village de la
campagne marocaine afin de présenter
l'activité apicole son rôle essentiel
pour notre écosystème et même de
remettre une ruche à une famille un
projet ambitieux au départ qui s'est
concrétisée sur place notamment grâce à
un très bel accueil il était vraiment
très content de nous recevoir
ils ont un peu l'habitude parce qu'il ya
une association qui travaille une
association française qui travaille
beaucoup avec eux
et les enfants sont très attentifs en
cours
même les professeurs étaient là où il
prenait des notes sur ce conte sur ce
qu'on disait etc même si on parle pas la
même langue on a pu communiquer et on a
pu leur remettre la ruche leur montrer
les premiers gestes en fait avec
l'enfumoir comment nourrir les abeilles
grâce à des plaquettes éducative une
ruche vitrée et l'aide d'un apiculteur
local diane et florian ont pu expliquer
aux enfants l'importance de la bei dans
notre biodiversité et partager avec les
habitants du village des moments
inoubliables humainement c'est quelque
chose
qui m'a beaucoup apporté parce que les
changes avec les enfants la famille et
même les habitants au maroc quelque
chose de fort on a pu partager des
moments comme jouer au foot ou même
quelques paroles parce que le contenu ne
parle pas entièrement français les
jeunes donc du coup c'était plus par le
geste et
en revenant après en france on se dit
qu'on a eu la chance de vivre cette
expérience au total dix équipages aux
projets écologiques étaient présents sur
la 17e édition du 4l trophy 2000 euros
étaient offerts aux meilleurs d'entre
eux si diane et florian terminent au
pied de la première marche à bord de
leur big 4 l c'est un projet de cinéma
solaire qui l'emportent cette année
c'est la fin de ce numéro d' équilibre
mais avant de se quitter on passe à
votre agenda environnementale jusqu'au
21 mai une exposition interactive vous
permettra d'en apprendre un peu plus sur
la transition écologique sous forme
d'activités les enfants et les parents
cherchent ensemble des solutions pour
économiser nos ressources dans plusieurs
domaines comme l'énergie l'eau la
biodiversité la pêche ou l'agriculture
c'est à la maison de l'environnement de
manif est amour et c'est gratuit deux
fois rendez vous encore à vous donner
avant de se quitter samedi 17 mai un
atelier vous propose une découverte de
la permaculture comment vivre
harmonieusement entre activité humaine
et protection notre écosystème rendez
vous dès 14 heures au jardin de la ferme
de bus loyer enfin le 21 mai
l'initiation ornithologique proposé par
la lpo vous attend à magny les hameaux
n'oubliez pas de vous munir de votre
paire de jumelles c'est la fin de cette
émission prochain rendez vous le 16 mai
et d'ici là n'oubliez pas la terre notre
mère
respectons la salut